once you see this stuff you can't unsee
it we live in such a gynocentric social
order and when i first heard this i was
thinking there is no way like men have
most of the power right we live in a
patriarchy but no no no women make 70 to
80 of consumer buying decisions so
everything we see in the media is
catered towards them and women are
bailed out of every bad decision they
make for example if a girl is
promiscuous she has birth control if the
birth control fails she has an abortion
if the abortion fails then she can go to
court and get child support from the
father if she gets married and the
marriage fails she can get alimony we
don't get as much prison time as men on
top of that if we don't get child
support and we're a single mother there
are government programs that pay for us
to be single mothers and if that goes
poorly and we end up homeless there's
women's shelters to bail us out or more
government benefits that we get that men
mostly pay into we own eighty percent of
the debt and what are they marketing in
america right now debt forgiveness we
make all of these poor decisions and
we're always bailed out what about the
men if they make a baby with someone
they shouldn't have they literally pay
for it for 18 years they marry the wrong
woman they could be paying alimony for
18 years not 18 years i don't know how
long alimony usually is if they end up
homeless there's not a bunch of men's
shelters around men have to deal with
the consequences of their bad decisions
but women we never do